Giants. Robots. Dragons. Gods….Clowns…
literally no one is safe from being taken
down by Monkey D. Luffy. The hero of
One Piece has spent decades punching
some of the most punchable faces ever to
appear in manga and anime and today we’re
talking about every single character that
Luffy has defeated throughout the story.
And the very first thing Luffy did when he
set sail as a pirate was punch the lights
out of the Lord of the Coast. He finally
got his revenge on the Sea King that took
Shanks’ arm in the form of a knuckle
sandwich - and in doing so he finally
proved he wasn’t the same kid he used to
be. Luffy was ready to be a real pirate.
After a poorly timed whirlpool, Luffy
found himself barreling toward the Alvida
Pirates…literally. After meeting his most
pink friend and future Hero of the Marines,
Koby, Luffy set the unwilling cabin
boy free by punching his boss - the
most beautiful pirate on the seas other
than Boa Hancock - right into the sea.
After that, Luffy ran into some opposition while
trying to recruit his first crewmate. ****A lot of
fans remember Luffy fighting Axe-Hand Morgan
after freeing Zoro on Shells Town. However,
Zoro was actually the one to finish the corrupt
captain off. In one of the biggest low diff
matchups of all time, Luffy actually defeats
Helmeppo, who was threatening Koby with a pistol.
And then immediately after that battle,
Luffy beat up Koby, in order to give
the marines of Shells Town the impression
that they aren’t actual allies. After all,
what kind of ally would beat the snot out of one
of his best friends? [whispered] (It’s the
kind who wants you to live out your dreams)
Moving over to Orange Town, Luffy came face
to face with the Lion Tamer Mohji and Richie
the Lion. And while Richie probably should
have been caged, it was actually Luffy who
found himself locked in a cage on this particular
occasion.However, nobody can keep Luffy locked up,
especially when he needs to fight on behalf
of Chou Chou, one of anime’s best dogs.
Luffy couldn’t settle for simply beating
up Mohji. He needed to fight his boss.
This was Luffy’s first fight against a fellow
devil fruit user, making it a real challenge,
but once Luffy and Nami managed to
tie up all of Buggy’s body parts,
Baby Buggy didn’t stand a chance and he got
Gum-Gum Bazooka’d into the stratosphere.
By the time the crew arrived in Syrup
village, Luffy had already taken out a lion
so Certified Cat Boy Captain Kuro didn’t
stand a chance. Kuro’s claws were sharp,
but Luffy’s wits were sharper…Okay, that’s
not accurate - Luffy doesn’t have any wits.
His strategy was actually just so dumb it
actually worked. He wrapped his rubbery
limbs all around Kuro so he couldn’t use
his speed to his advantage and then gave
him the headbutt to end all headbutts
in the form of a Gomu Gomu no Bell.
All that Syrup Village business really worked
up an appetite, so Luffy and the gang’s next
stop was the floating restaurant, Baratie.
Unfortunately, they weren’t the only ones
who showed up without a reservation. Along
came Don Krieg, who led the largest fleet
in all of the East Blue. After Dracule Mihawk
sliced up his fleet and ships in the Grand Line,
he tried to take the Baratie for himself. However,
despite his underhanded tactics of using poison,
spikes, cannons, and more - he couldn’t compare
with Luffy’s brute strength and was wiped out.
With Don Krieg defeated, there was only one pirate
left in the East Blue who was more powerful and
infamous: Arlong. This sawshark fishman gave
Luffy his most difficult fight yet, but the
stakes were personal. The fight ended in the map
room where Arlong had tortured Nami, forcing her
to draw maps since her childhood. He brought down
Arlong and his entire park with a Gum Gum Axe.
Entering the Grand Line, Luffy wouldn’t take
another W until Little Garden where he went up
against the Candle Man Mr. 3 - whose real name
is Galdino, it turns out. Most of the crew was
nearly turned into a Wax Museum, but Luffy Waxed
On and Waxed Off until Galdino was Gal-decimated.
On Drum Island, Luffy dethroned
Wapol, a cruel king with a bad
case of the munch-munchies. This was
the first monarch Luffy would punch,
but it certainly wouldn’t be the last and
in doing so he turned the Drum Kingdom
into a democracy when Dalton was elected the
leader of the newly dubbed Sakura Kingdom.
And Luffy went from beating his first king to his
first Warlord, when Luffy defeated Crocodile in
round 3 of their fight. After being knocked
down twice by the sand user, Luffy beat him
up using nothing but his own blood, sweat, and
tears…but mostly his blood, which hardened the
logia user’s sand and allowed him to be battered
right through the ceiling of the Tomb of the King.
The crew’s next destination was Jaya, where Luffy
was able to demonstrate how much he’d grown to
resemble his mentor, Shanks. When Bellamy picked a
fight and made fun of Luffy’s dreams, he sat there
and took it because he wasn’t worth the trouble.
But when Bellamy hurt one of Luffy’s friends,
then Luffy got serious. The spring-spring man
bounced all around Jaya, but Luffy didn’t need
to use his devil fruit at all. All it took was a
single punch to break Bellamy the Hyena’s spirit.
Once Luffy and co found themselves on Skypiea,
they went up against Enel’s Priests. Luffy
helped Sanji out against Satori, but Sanji made
the finishing blow. Luffy’s real battle on the
island was against God. Or at least, somebody
who considered himself a God. Enel had never
met an opponent who wasn’t instantly incinerated
by his lightning strikes, but was in for a huge
surprise when Luffy’s rubber body was completely
immune to his attacks. Even without his lightning,
Enel still put up quite a fight using his
observation haki, which he called “Mantra.”
However, in the end Luffy defeated him
and rang the bell in the City of Gold.
The next opponent was back on the Blue Sea on
Long Ring Long Land, when Foxy the Silver Fox
challenged the Straw Hats to a Davy Back
Fight. In the final round of the game,
the two captains had a one v one match up.
However, Foxy’s Slow-Slow beam was so hard
to deal with that it took Luffy’s ultimate form
to defeat him: Afro Luffy. Despite Foxy’s tricks
and traps, nothing could defeat the boxing
prowess of Afro Luffy, and he won the round.
The next opponent was even more difficult for
Luffy to fight than the near- invincible Foxy.
However, this one wasn’t physically difficult,
it was emotionally difficult. On Water 7,
Usopp challenged Luffy for the ownership
of the Going Merry, the crew’s ship that
needed to be replaced and suffering extreme
damage on their adventures. Usopp used all
of the resources and knowledge he’d gained about
Luffy’s weaknesses throughout their adventures,
but ultimately was completely
outclassed by his captain’s strength.
When the crew stormed Enies Lobby, Luffy’s
first victim was the CP9 agent Blueno,
who ate the Door-Door fruit. However, even for
someone who can make doors anywhere, there was
no escape from the insane speed of Luffy’s Gear 2.
The fight against Blueno was Oda’s way of showing
off the strength of Luffy’s new Gear techniques
before Luffy fought his real opponent of the arc:
Rob Lucci. This leopard zoan fruit user
gave Luffy his toughest fight yet. This
CP9 Power House was willing to carry out
any order on behalf of the government,
all to satisfy his immense bloodlust.
Lucci devastated Luffy with the secret
techniques called the Six Powers,
particularly his strongest attack:
The Rokuogan. However, Lucci finally met defeat
on the receiving end of Luffy’s Jet Gatling Gun.
Before leaving ****Water 7, Luffy’s
grandpa showed up to crash the party,
leading to a quick rematch with
Koby. As everyone would predict,
Koby didn’t stand a chance - but he
sure is getting stronger, though!
Luffy’s next terrifying opponent
was on the horror-themed island of
Thriller Bark. The Warlord Gecko Moria
resurrected his ultimate zombie, Oars,
from the body of a fearsome Ancient Giant. Things
looked bleak for the Straw Hats, but Luffy took
a ton of shadows into his own body in order to
transform into Nightmare Luffy and crushed Oars.
Up next was Moria himself, the next Warlord to
fall to Straw Hat Luffy. Even when Moria used
Shadow’s Asgard to suck 1,000 shadows
into himself and boost his strength,
he wasn’t able to beat Luffy. With every punch,
Moria spit up shadows, unable to control the
power of so many at once. After that fight,
though, nothing happened on Thriller Bark.
When the crew arrived at Sabaody Archipelago, they
were ready to tackle the New World. Unfortunately,
those plans went sideways when they went to rescue
their mermaid friend Camie from a slave auction.
****When the Celestial Dragon St. Charlos shoots
Hatchan, Luffy does the morally correct thing
that anyone should do when encountering a
slave owner and punches him into oblivion.
After Kuma gives Luffy an all-expenses
paid trip to Amazon Lily, he finds
himself in Trial by Combat against a black
panther. But as the real King of the Jungle,
Luffy showed Bacura the panther who’s boss.
After that, Boa Hancock’s sisters Marigold
and Sandersonia went up against Luffy.
Luffy probably would have taken a definitive
victory, but the match was called off when
Luffy went out of his way to hide the Mark of
the Celestial Dragons on the Gorgon Sisters’
backs from the women of Amazon Lily,
thus stealing Boa’s heart for life.
For the whole Marineford Saga, Luffy was
way out of his element. He took out a lot of
fodder in Impel Down, but he failed to take out
any big opponents.Luffy was truly in his L era
here. However, the ever-dependable Koby was there
as always to be taken down by Luffy in one hit.
And technically, Luffy did
also knock out his own grandpa,
Garp the Hero of the Marines. I mean, Garp
didn’t fight back whatsoever…but still,
he did knock him down on the
way to the executioner’s stand.
After taking a couple years off to power up, Luffy
was back in business when he returned to Sabaody
Archipelago and took out the Pacifistas that
used to give him trouble like they were nothing.
While descending to Fishman Island,
Luffy made friends with a giant
kraken the only way he knows how…by
punching it as hard as he could.
However, he wasn’t trying to make
friends when he punched Hody Jones,
the leader of the New Fishman Pirates as hard as
he could. The battle against Hody Jones proved
just how much stronger Luffy had become
over the timeskip. Hody Jones was powered
up by an insane amount of Energy Steroids,
and was fighting against a fishman while
underwater…even though he was a devil fruit user.
And even with that massive handicap, Luffy took
him out and destroyed the giant ark, the Noah,
with his Red Hawk and Elephant Gun techniques.
The Straw Hats’ next destination was Punk Hazard,
where Luffy lost the first round to Caesar Clown
who deprived him of oxygen using his devil fruit
powers. However, in round two of the fight,
Luffy figures out Caesar’s trick and learns
the distance he has to stay away in order to
keep breathing. Luffy clowns on this Clown
with his awesome Grizzly Magnum technique.
After Punk Hazard, Luffy partnered up with
Trafalgar Law and the allies went to take
down Doflamingo. Well, actually they went to
destroy the Smile factory so that Kaidou would
take down Doflamingo, but we all know how
well Luffy can follow a plan. So instead,
Oda brought us to a gladiator match where
a suspiciously familiar contestant named
Lucy fought to try to get the Mera
Mera no Mi that once belonged to Ace.
At the coliseum, Lucy, who was shockingly
revealed to be Luffy in disguise easily
brought down the giant Hajrudin, who
would go on to join his Grand Fleet.
He also fought an old pirate named Don Chinjao
who was once a rival of Luffy’s grandpa,
Garp. Despite Luffy having nothing to do with
that old conflict, Chinjao held a grudge and
wanted to take it out on Luffy. This gave
Luffy a chance to practice his conqueror’s
haki and with a powerful punch, he gave Don
Chinjao the pointy head he missed so much back.
After Chinjao, though, came the first
real test of Luffy’s strength since the
timeskip. Everyone Luffy fought to this
point, he hadn’t had to give his all,
but Doflamingo pushed him to the limit, forcing
him to reveal his new ultimate technique:
Gear 4. Base Luffy couldn’t keep up with
Doflamingo’s crazy strength and speed,
but once he transformed into Gear 4, Bounce
Man wiped the smile off of Doflamingo’s face
and he defeated the Celestial Dragon and
ended his terrible reign over Dressrosa.
Cracker
After Dressrosa, the crew set their eyes on
the Four Emperors. In order to save Sanji,
Luffy invaded Big Mom’s territory of Whole
Cake Island. In order to get him back,
Luffy had to take down two of her
Sweet Commanders. First was Cracker,
the warrior who fought with hardened
biscuit soldiers. Unfortunately,
Cracker couldn’t make enough biscuits to deal
with Luffy’s appetite. After eating his fill,
Luffy used those extra calories to turn
into Tank Man, and Cracker got cooked.
Katakuri
Luffy’s hardest fight yet, though, came in the
form of Katakuri - the future sight master who
could predict his every move. Katakuri’s stretchy
mochi fruit gave him the mirror image of Luffy’s
own powers, which was fitting since their
fight took place in the mirror world. Over
the course of their long battle, Luffy developed
his observation haki, allowing him to see briefly
into the future. The battle almost ended in a
draw, with both fighters seemingly down for the
count, but Luffy was able to get back up and
escape Whole Cake Island with his crewmates.
In act I of Wano, Luffy’s first
opponent was the Sumo champion
Urashima. Despite Urashima’s superior
weight class, he was no match for Luffy.
This lion-bellied Gifter on Kaidou’s crew was
also outclassed by Luffy, who defeated him with
a Red Hawk attack, reminding O’Tama of Luffy’s
brother Ace. Of course, none of these battles on
Wano really required Luffy to go all out. None
except the person you’ve all been waiting for:
Kaidou: The World’s Strongest Creature
gave Luffy the fight of his life. Kaidou’s
draconic transformation and command of advanced
conqueror’s haki made this emperor more powerful
than any foe Luffy had fought before. In fact,
Kaidou was so strong that he defeated him twice
and then seemingly literally killed him after
that. Unfortunately for Kaidou, that led to Luffy
awakening his devil fruit. After that Gear 5 Luffy
went Looney Tunes, using dragon form Kaidou as a
jump rope and sending the King of Beasts to the
magma beneath Wano’s Mt. Fuji. With this battle,
Luffy truly became Joyboy’s successor and earned
his title as one of the Four Emperors of the Sea.
After the Land of Wano, the crew headed to Egghead
Island where they reunited with some old rivals:
Rob Lucci and Kaku, who had been promoted
to CP0. These guys seem to fail upward just
as much as Buggy. Even though Rob Lucci had
also awakened his zoan fruit just like Luffy,
he just couldn’t keep up with the
wild abilities of Gear 5 and was
at a disadvantage when Stussy ended
the fight by putting Lucci to sleep.
A much more suitable opponent for Gear 5 Luffy
is the admiral who showed up after CP0: Kizaru,
who demolished the crew alongside Kuma two
years prior at Sabaody Archipelago. However,
now Gear 5 Luffy can fight the Light
Fruit user on roughly equal footing,
the match ending essentially in a
draw with both fighters immobilized.
But if this match was a tie, what about the
matches that Luffy outright lost? Most of the
time through sheer willpower, Luffy is
able to pull ahead and beat characters
many times stronger than himself. However,
on surprisingly numerous occasions on One
Piece he’s been fully and utterly defeated.
How many times? And by who? Well, you can
find out exactly when and how Luffy has lost
throughout the series in this video right here.